with the rise of the islamic state or
daesh back in 2014
we witnessed the terrible and awful
crimes that they committed against the
religious minorities in the region
and some of the worst of these crimes
were committed against the yazidi
community particularly in the sinjar
mountain
region which garnered a lot of
international attention of course
but this also led a lot of people to ask
the question
who are the yazidis and what is the
yazidi religion
the yazidis are referred to as an
ethno-religious community and one that
is specifically connected to the kurdish
people of northern iraq
in regions like sheikhan the sinjar
mountains and
in the region of lalesh now what we mean
by ethno-religious
community is that the religion and
ethnicity
is so strongly interconnected that we
cannot really separate one
from the other and this is sort of shown
by the fact that your religious
identity as a yazidi is primarily
determined by your parents
being yazidis and that the religion
doesn't accept any converts we usually
understand religion from a very
modern and often christian centric
framework
in which religion is often separated
from things like politics or
ethnicity but this example shows us that
the
world of religions are a lot more
complex than that and that these
divisions aren't usually all
that clear at all the name yazidi is
contested and there's no consensus on
where it came from or why it was applied
to this group in particular
some connected to the middle persian
word yazad which means divine being
others think its origins may have been
the name of the second umayyad caliph
yazid ibn mu'awya
whom the group that became the yazidis
are said to have sympathized with
yezidism has for the majority of history
and even still today been a primarily
oral tradition this means that there are
no sacred texts or canonical collections
of text in which their beliefs or
practices are
gathered or have a sort of direct source
instead beliefs and practices have been
orally transmitted by the religious
leaders throughout the centuries
this also means that there are many
different often competing understandings
of basic tenets
and elements of the religion and a huge
variety
in how its practitioners understand and
often relate to it
this of course is true for all religions
but particularly so
for yezidism because of its very strong
oral tradition and the lack of
any texts at all basically there is no
proclamation of
faith that yazidis affirm and no unity
in terms of performing rights or prayers
or how these are to be performed
this means that it's hard to talk about
the yazidis in any kind of generalizing
terms
but there are a few you could say
generalizations that we can make
about the general ideas or theological
uh tendencies and and practices of this
religion
yazidism is usually described as a
monotheistic religion
this means that they believe in one
almighty god who has many names
including
and allah arguably then this is the same
god as the abrahamic faiths as
yazidism share many of the mythological
basics of these religions
which we will see but this one god is so
transcendent that he kind of is
uninterested in earthly or
worldly affairs instead he focuses on
heavenly affairs
and leaves the sort of ruling or
governing of the world
to seven angels and these angels are
called the haftsur or the heftad
the most powerful and important of these
angels they are called malik taus
the peacock angel he is the leader of
the seven angels and have been
given the responsibility to do god's
will on earth
melechtaus or the peacock angel has thus
become one of the most prominent and
important symbols
for yazidism as you can see on many
logos or in many
well just generally in symbols to
represent this religion another
prominent symbol used by yazidis is the
sun
which represents god and his creative
power and
as a result of this yazidis prey facing
the sun these angels are also thought to
be able to take human form
almost like an avatar in the hindu
tradition and have done so throughout
history
these incarnations are known as khas as
an example some yazidis believe that
jesus and the early
muslim theologian and mystic hasan
al-basri
was are two examples of this khas the
yazidis also believe in the process of
reincarnation after death
rather than the more common monotheistic
concept of heaven and hell
the origins of the yazidi religion is
another point of contention where there
really isn't any consensus
they share the mythological background
stories of the abrahamic faiths
and they trace their religion to adam
the first
man in fact they often hold that their
people are descended from a miraculously
born
son of adam called shahid
from that point on the azir religion is
often traced through babylonian
sumerian and mithraic cultures
what is perhaps most important to
yazidis that they consider their
religions to be
or their religion to be the original
religion of the kurdish
people and that all kurds before the
coming of islam
were yazidis thus there's a clear line
often drawn here between
yezidism and islam which one should
accept in one sense
but that division or strong division
also becomes slightly problematic when
we view
the more scholarly historical evidence
in fact the azidism enters the world
stage in the 12th century
and particularly in the region of lalesh
which is still a
sort of central region for the religion
today
here they seem to have first appeared as
followers of a sufi sheikh by the name
adi ibn musafir
and more commonly known simply as sheikh
adi he seems to have come originally
from modern day lebanon and later
studied in baghdad under
or along with some of the most famous
sufi scholars in history
like abdulhadra al-jilani founder of the
khandaria order
and the two al-razali brothers
ahmadineed
it seems that later in his life he chose
to live a life of seclusion
and resettled in lalesh in the kurdish
mountains where he founded a sufi order
that he called the adawiya
this sufi order the adawaya many
scholars argue
is the foundations that would become
yazidism later on
it was very characteristic of sufi
sheikhs and missionaries in particular
to be more let's say tolerant or open
towards
local traditions in regions that they
sort of
went into so they would often
in their practice adopt local practices
of the older religion or tradition and
sort of give it a new islamic
clothing to sort of easily transition
the population to a new muslim
identity this fact along with the
geographical isolation
of the region of radish and its people
and the sufi order
led to its gradual development away from
its sort of
sufi or islamic roots into its
completely
own tradition eventually both yazidis
themselves and
modern historians and scholars agree on
the importance of
sheikh adi for the religion of yazidism
but they have different perspectives on
who he was
yazidis often say that he was a reformer
of the ur
sort of already existing yazidi religion
and there are different opinions on
whether this was a good or bad thing
those in favor him often claim that he
sort of
he was never actually a muslim but
really a yazidi in disguise who only
claimed to be a muslim
to avoid being persecuted by the sunni
majority
scholars and historians however agree
that in sheikh
these writings we find no trace of
yazidism and that by all accounts
he seems to have been an orthodox sufi
muslim
who preached a or created a sufi order
that was within the fold of the
sort of mainstream islamic religion
and that the sort of deviation or
separation into its own
religion eventually sort of happened or
developed after his death
these possible roots in sufism can also
sometimes be very clearly seen for
example in terminology used in the
religious practice
yazidism and its people are very much
divided into a kind of caste
system and in this caste system there
are a number of castes obviously the
lower castes of the majority are known
as murids
above them are the peers or elders who
function as spiritual guides and
religious clergy basically and lastly
the highest caste which are the
sheikhs or masters who seem to have had
a rather similar role to the peers
but even more exalted they are sometimes
thought to have healing powers
for example for those of you who know
your sufism or sufi terminology you'll
recognize these terms as they are the
same words that are used in the
hierarchy of the sufi orders or in the
sufi
practice generally murid in sufism
denotes a student
of a master also known as a sheikh peer
is also often used as a name
for the sort of leader of a certain sufi
order
in any case these castes have played and
still do play an important role in
yazidi practice
like with many other religions yazidism
can be characterized primarily as a
religion of orthopraxy
rather than orthodoxy this means that
they put more emphasis
on sort of cultural and traditional
practices and
and on taboo and things like that rather
than having certain beliefs or following
a theological doctrine
the caste system and the ethnic unity of
the yazidi people
is very important this means that one is
very rarely allowed to marry
outside of the religion and usually not
allowed to marry
across castes either this is in fact
even more
frowned upon than marrying outside of
the religion altogether
so the role of murider sheikh is
hereditary if one marries outside the
religion that person is usually
excommunicated and no longer considered
a yazidi
the actual practice of the religion is
often connected to these ideas of taboo
and different traditional cultural
practices
there are festivals celebrated around
the year like the yazidi new year which
is celebrated in april
but the most important festival of the
year is probably the one known as jamia
or the
feast of assembly the festival of
assembly
which takes place over the course of
seven days
and this festival is sort of celebrated
in honor of sheikh
adi and during this festival yazidis
make a pilgrimage to
sheikh adi's grave in lalesh and
there they perform religious rites they
listen to kaul religious hymns and
stories
and generally just get together as a
community
[Music]
also traditionally do personal daily
prayers which
are said to be five as with other
minority groups the yazidis have
in a lot of periods received less than
ideal treatment
they have for a large portion of history
been under the rule of
muslim empires and kingdoms and this
on and off persecution oppression by the
muslims
can be traced as in so many other cases
to social and political factors
so during the ottoman era for example
the yazidis were sometimes tolerated
usually when they could be beneficial to
the ottoman state and the sultans by
serving in the army
or things like this but in other periods
they were
often very much oppressed and persecuted
for
according to the ottomans not paying
their taxes and
refusing to serve in the army and of
course there is also a religious
or there is religious grounds for much
of this persecution as
many christians and muslims in history
have referred to yazidis
as devil worshipers this is related to
the story of the highest angel that i
mentioned called malik taus
and according to yazidis malek taus was
asked by god
to bow to adam the first man to which he
refused
because he didn't want to bow to anyone
except god
himself so this was done out of love for
god and because of this
he was exalted as the highest of the
angels he was given the highest position
now of course this is similar or almost
identical to the story of
iblis or satan in the quran and the
biblical account
was also asked to bow to adam to which
he refused but in that story god then
punishes him for this refusal to follow
god's orders
and so this is why some christians and
muslims have identified
the malektaus of the yazidis
with the devil or lucifer of the
abrahamic faiths
this claim of course the yazidis deny
but being called devil worshipers
doesn't exactly help your reputation
and has often led to violence or
justification for violence such as with
the islamic state in 2014
but as a result of things like this the
yazidis were often not considered
the among the people of the book the
kitab
to the muslims and thus didn't retain
the same rights as
groups like christians or jews or
sometimes zoroastrians and so on
by the end of the ottoman era the
yazidis migrated from the middle east to
a large extent and after the events of
2014
migration has become even more prominent
it's hard to know how many yazidis there
are currently in the world estimates can
range between 200
000 to over a million the large
population that previously lived in the
sinjar mountains
was severely minimized in 2014 with the
genocide
as 80 percent fled to other regions or
other parts of the world
completely yazidism therefore has a
significant diaspora community in europe
today
the new situation of entering the
regions of the world that they
historically haven't and living as a
diaspora community
has led to as it often does to questions
regarding
integration and the levels to which one
allows the religion to be adapted to the
new societies
a prime example of this is the fact that
yazidis traditionally haven't been
allowed to learn how to read or write
except those in the highest or smallest
sheikh
cast reasons for this doctrine isn't all
that clear
some say it was meant to keep the
religious teaching secret and confined
to the
lineage the religious sort of clergy
others say was to avoid being educated
in islamic
and sort of educational systems and
schools nonetheless as the yezidis
entered new regions like
europe it could become quite a problem
if you didn't know how to read or write
and so these doctrines of these ideas
have been
sort of loosened up and since the 1950s
the yazidis especially in diaspora
communities have
tended to be allowed to read and write
and this is just one example of other
sort of forms of discussions and debates
about the
levels of compromise or integration
that is allowed to modify religious
traditions so as you can see yazidism is
a very diverse and complex
ethno-religious community that is very
hard to define
in a lot of cases it is clear that even
if it does have its origins in a sufi
order in the adawaya of sheikh adi as
many claim
it has throughout history developed into
its own religion and its own unique
tradition completely that is separated
from the religion of islam
and thus it can tell us a lot about the
myriad and
vast array of different religious groups
and minorities
that exist in the middle east today i'll
see you next time
boom